les habitudes vont changer pour les
amoureux de la grande bretagne français
et européens pourront toujours se rendre
à londres avec leur carte d'identité
jusqu'en octobre 2021 est passée cette
date un passeport sera nécessaire et si
votre séjour dépasse six mois alors un
visa sera aussi exigé se déplacer marché
conduire là aussi les règles changent
si vous visitez le royaume uni après le
1er janvier 2021
vous devriez pouvoir conduire avec votre
permis français accompagnés d'une
traduction anglaise ce point est
cependant toujours en négociation et le
permis de conduire international
pourraient être exigés pour conduire au
royaume uni à partir du 1er janvier
vos chances d'émigrés outre-manche vont
se réduire le gouvernement britannique
comme des pour un système d'immigration
au mérite
l'âge la maîtrise de l'anglais les
ressources financières seront scrutés
une promesse d'embauché capitale à noter
que certains corps de métiers comme les
médecins les ingénieurs ou encore les
architectes devront désormais faire
reconnaître leur qualification
concernant les expatriés français actuel
ils ont jusqu'au 31 joueurs pour faire
leur demande de statut de résidents
travailleurs étudiants même combat les
conditions se durcissent avec des frais
de scolarité nous conséquent pour eux
payer la même chose qu'un étudiant
britannique n'est plus d'actualité
si votre voyage linguistique des pas six
mois l'achat d'un visa est recommandée
il en coûtera 390 euros ajoutés aux 557
euros pour bénéficier du service de
santé publique
les candidats devront démontrer qu'ils
ont une offre d'un établissement
d'enseignement agréé qu'ils peuvent
subvenir à leurs besoins financiers et
qu'ils parlent anglais
plus question non plus d'introduire dans
le pays des produits d'origine animale à
base de viande ou de produits laitiers
annonce le gouvernement britannique
le traditionnel jambon beurre est dans
la ligne de mire le pâté le saucisson le
beurre ou encore le yaourt seront donc
analysé pour éviter que des maladies ne
propage dans le royaume les pâtisseries
biscuits et bonbons ne sont pas
concernés tout comme les aliments pour
nourrissons
enfin la question des appels
téléphoniques n'est pas encore réglé
orange et bouygues telecom disent
vouloir maintenir le statu quo en ne
taxons pas l'utilisation de la 4g free
et sfr n'ont pas encore officiellement
communiqué à ce sujet